these six oil executives five of them us
citizens had already been stuck in
venezuelan prison for years
now they've finally been tried found
guilty of corruption
and received sentences of between eight
and thirteen years
whatever he wants to do with that this
letter is from one of them
tomo valdel it's the first public
message from any of the men since their
arrest
he wrote it just before his trials
conclusion
his lawyer reads it
now reaching the crossroads where if
justice is done i'll be able to rebuild
my life and try to
compensate my family for the last
moments the light is intense
the hope is great give me freedom
freedom was denied to him human rights
advocates say that venezuela's justice
system
is plagued with corruption and
efficiency and political bias
his lawyer again
in tomorrow's case there is no evidence
it's not there is no circumstantial
evidence
or no indirect evidence or flawed
evidence
there is no evidence none period
al jazeera asked the team of venezuela's
attorney general tarek williams
for his response about the cases the
answer
no comment the men worked for oil
companies sicko
they were arrested and charged with
embezzlement after being lured to a
business meeting in venezuela three
years ago
their cases played out against the
backdrop of the acrimonious relationship
between president nicolas maduro and the
trump administration
like many other countries the u.s
supported maduro's rival juan guay does
claim to the presidency
we want to get every american u.s
secretary of state mike pompeo
has indicated that he believes the six
men are being used as political hostages
despite that before the trial's verdict
vadel's family were hopeful he would be
home for future thanksgivings
just like the ones they used to
celebrate together so i think
my father wants to share to the world
that
he a message of love of hope
and of justice he's been held for
you know over three years unjustly and
and now there's a glimmer of hope
with the trial ongoing now that trial is
over
for the six men and their families hope
appears to be waning
john holman al jazeera